على كل المزيد معنا من مقر مجلس الشيوخ في
باريس ينضم الينا الان جيل بيرجيه وهو عضو
لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه في مجلس الشيوخ
الفرنسي اهلا بك سيد جيلبس محلا ان ابدا
بالاعدامات واخرها تم الاعلان عنها الان
اعدام ايراني جديد لاحد المحتجين كيف
تقيمين تقيمون هذه الاعدامات هل تعتبر
مرفوضه من اصلها كليا او انه لا يجب ان
تكون مترويه نوعا ما الحكومه الايرانيه في
التعاطي مع هذا الملف
يمكن سوق بلاي
يستخدمون الدين لغرات سياسيه وهذا سوف
يؤدي الى انكار انتماء هذا النظام للدين
ونحن هنا في فرنسا نطالب باستدعاء كافه
سفراء الاتحاد
[موسيقى]
الكثير من الاموال خارجه ايران من اجل
اعاده هذه الاموال الى الشعب الايراني
في هذه او اتخاذ مثل هذه الاجراءات التي
تطلبونها البعض كان يقول بانه الدول
الاوروبيه بصوره عامه وفرنسا تحديدا ربما
كانت تحاول استرضاء النظام الايراني هل
هذا واقعي
ليس هناك اي مرورنا في الموقف الذي نتبناه
حيايا
النظام الايراني نحن هنا في مجلس الشيوخ
نتبنا موقفا صار لمن والحكومه ايضا جددت
موقفها اثار وهذا هو الموقف الذي نتبناه
نحن ايضا ان تنمي الى المعارضه يجب تبني
موقف صار رمحياله هذا النظام
الديكتاتور الذي يجب ان يغادر سلطه في
ايران هناك بعض التحركات من قبل برلمانيين
ان كان في النمسا ان كان في المانيا
وغيرها من الدول تتبنى قضايا معتقلين
بعينها هل تعتقد انه مثل هذه الخطوات
مجديه وهل هناك من يتبعها في فرنسا
الدولي
ممثل السفاره الايرانيه اليوم الى وزاره
الخارجيه الفرنسيه وهذا يدل على ان فرنسا
والبرلمانيين الفرنسيين لا يؤيدون
الاستمرار في ترك هذا النظام الوحشي يعذب
وينفذ احكام الاعدام لانه يتمتع بنوع من
الديمقراطيه في ايران
ولكنه ايضا هذا الاستدعاء ايضا يؤكد انه
النظام لا يابا لا بتحركاتهم ولا بايض
ضغوطات حتى الان مفروضه على النظام لانه
قبل ان
نبدا بهذا اللقاء كان هناك اعلان عن اعلان
جديد
ولا يمكن ان اصدق ان هناك امكانيه للحوار
مع هذا النظام من يتحاور مع الايرانيين
اليوم فقد روسيا وروسيا في حاله حرب مع
اوكرانيا من اجل الحصول على مسيرتهم
المشكلاتين ليس هناك بلد يدعم ايران
بلدان الخليفه وفتعد ايضا بشكل
سفرائهم من ايران
اوروبي وفرنسي تحديدا لنظام الايراني ولكن
هل التوجه هو لتغيير النظام كليا تغيير
فقط ام ماذا
حقيقيه و ضروريه في هذا البلد الشباب
والنساء يطمحون لذلك هم يطمحون في حياه
يتمتعون في كان فيها بالكرامه لا يمكن ان
يعيشوا في نظام يعذب والوضع الان اسوء من
ما كان عليه الحال في نظام الشاه
كان معنا اذا من مقر مجلس الشيوخ في باريس
جلبير روجيه عضو لجنه الشؤون الخارجيه في
مجلس الشيوخ الفرنسي شكرا جزيلا لك على
هذه المشاركه